vom 14 17 oktober 2009 10 wird in ungarn
die zivil-militärische grenzschutz übung
kooperativ security 2009 10 kurz
kopschek 19 der zentraleuropäischen
verteidigungs kooperation der central
european defence corporation kurz gdc
durchgeführt mit der kopf 19 wird eine
gemeinsame regionale übung mit fokus auf
die bewältigung von illegaler migration
bereits zum zweiten mal erfolgreich
absolviert nachdem die erste kopschek in
österreich 2017 stattgefunden hat wir
kommen also hier mit erfahrenen
profitieren wir kommen mit technischen
elementen der aufklärung der zeox
dementen bodenradar und jungen der
verteidigungs kooperation gehören neben
österreich die zentraleuropäischen
staaten tschechien slowakei ungarn
slowenien und kroatien an
wichtig ist dass bei diesen übungen alle
staaten dabei sind signalisiert wird
dass diese kooperation nicht nur eine
diplomatische worthülse ist sondern dass
sie auch unterfüttert wird mit
praktischen übungen und dem willen im
fall des falles an operationen
teilzunehmen
ziel der grenzschutz übung ist das
migrations aufkommen an der grenze
zwischen ungarn und einem fiktiven
nachbarland kurz yellow land mit zivil-
militärischen kräften unter kontrolle zu
bringen
insgesamt beteiligen sich an der coque
19 über 400 angehörige der polizei sowie
der streitkräfte aus cdc staaten sowie
polizei und grenzschutz truppen aus
polen
das österreichische bundesheer hat mit
30 personen teilgenommen gab es hat sich
sehr deutlich gezeigt dass österreich
und die anderen teilnahmen staaten und
vor allem auch ungarn sehr gut
zusammenarbeiten können und gemeinsam
szenarien überdenken die entstehen
könnten oder wie man mit situationen die
in der vergangenheit entstanden sind
noch besser umgehen kann